let's bring in florida governor ron
desantis almost knows he knows all about
the challenges of getting therapeutics
for his state as well as testing
governor always great to see you
at the even your critics would say
you're a man of action we're in a
nationwide shortage when it comes to
tests do you have something to say to
the people of florida
yeah brian you know the uh by the
administration promised they were going
to send all these at-home tests they
said all you had to do was go online and
get it and nothing has happened in a
month and a half with doing that and so
we look at it in florida and say you
know the the point of matter is not
every single person needs to be going
out always getting tested you have
healthy people that's not a good
strategy but what is a good strategy is
to have these at-home tests available
for a vulnerable population and so we've
secured a million at-home tests we're
going to be distributing them to nursing
homes and long-term care facilities
throughout the state of florida and then
to the broader senior communities
throughout our population because
we view testing as something that should
lead to then a clinical result and so
we've embraced early treatments in
florida so if you have somebody that's
elderly that may be vulnerable to covid
they can get a quick test at home
they'll gotta wait in line and then if
they're positive they have the ability
potentially to get treatments now we
would like to have more treatments but
the federal government is uh is being
very scarce with those and so we're
fighting for more so that floridians get
what they need
sure absolutely and so
it it's amazing that you're able to
announce details uh before the federal
government is because you would think
the federal government you know that
they're the
the whole enchilada they should be able
to do things whereas you have taken
obviously matters into your own hands to
try to get it to the people but you know
i like the what you have just said uh
regarding the fact that you are not
everybody needs to be tested but the
vulnerable do because
ultimately what we're seeing with the
omicron is you know my whole family had
it around christmas time and we didn't
know we had it and it wasn't until one
of us got i i got the first test where
it's like okay you need to keep away
from your family it was too late i'd
already infected everybody
but you got to stay away from grandma
and that's what you're talking about
with the most vulnerable because people
do need to be vaccinated boosted and and
tested to keep everybody safe
well that's the thing i think you have a
situation where omicron thankfully is
much less pathogenic than delta you see
it dramatically fewer hospital
admissions and a lot of the hospital
missions in florida and around the
country are people who are getting
admitted for something else and just
happen to test positive but they're not
actually sick enough from kova to be
treated in a hospital and so that is um
in many ways a good development for how
this thing has evolved but you do have
vulnerable people and elderly people and
those are the folks that we want to make
sure that we're able to help but the
idea that somehow if you're just a young
and healthy person you just need to be
going out and getting tested four or
five times a week or that you should
force people to test to be able to go to
school or to be able to do their job
that is not a good use of resources and
that's part of the reason why
you're seeing the shortage because you
have a lot of low value testing going on
so governor there's an article in vanity
fair that says in october there was a
proposal they approached biden about you
need to buy a lot of these tests you
need to buy 732 million tests because we
need to be prepared for the holiday
search so many i know a lot of new
yorkers went down to florida i'm sure a
lot of others did too because people
didn't want to go out of the country
because you couldn't come back in if you
were positive and you could be positive
for months so this put a lot of pressure
on you and your state to make sure you
had a lot of these tests we all came
down there we were looking for tests in
the middle of the vacation the tests
were gone at cvs's and at walgreens and
at grocery stores in kroger and we would
get phone calls they have them at kroger
this morning we would rush over there
and they just sold out so now that
you've ordered all of these extra tests
when can we expect those to be in the
krogers and in the walgreens or cvs's
down there
well these will likely go to uh we're
gonna go to nursing homes long-term care
facilities and then likely go to local
communities where they can focus them on
elderly people i agree i think we need
to have the shelves restocked
commercially we had had really no
problem with that for months and months
but because omicron is so widespread you
see that i think that there actually
will be some ketchup on that ainsley
because i think there was an initial
panic when omicron hit there was a lot
of media hysteria and now i think people
are starting to understand hey this is
something that's out there but for most
people it is more akin to it to a cold
or a flu and that's a great thing and so
you don't necessarily need to be going
out and doing these tests for no reason
test if there's a reason clinically to
be able to generate an outcome and so i
think what we did will be helpful but i
do think you're going to start to see
more and more of those tests in the
stores
a couple of things uh governor you
mentioned therapeutics you mentioned uh
the the monaco mcconnell antibodies
also the pfizer he ordered another 10
million pfizer we have 20 million pfizer
pills you need five pills in 30 days and
once you get this so steve wouldn't have
this or anyone watching us right now the
omnicron you'd get right through it
quickly and now you see the pullback on
therapeutics the president was
dismissive of why you're not going to
need the pills but we have the pills
why do you think the federal government
does not want us to have therapeutics
well i think if you look back there's a
number of big failures in this pandemic
the school closures which i know you
guys were talking about you know some of
the lockdown policies of course but the
failure from the outset to really focus
on therapeutics i think it's cost a huge
number of lives
it was almost like they said
lock down mask and then once vaccines
came vaccine and that was it and as
we've seen now particularly with omicron
is you know people are still getting
infected regardless of their vaccination
status so you need to have an emphasis
on therapeutics i just think it's
counter to their messaging and their
narratives intentionally rolled out our
monoclonal antibody sites over the
summer they attacked me because they
said oh then this is not you you're
against vaccine if you're for
therapeutics when actually we had a lot
of vaccinated people that were going it
wasn't all unvaccinated
but regardless you want to have
treatment options and so in florida
we've really stressed that our surgeon
general joe latipo has done a good job
talking about it um but yes it's been a
huge huge problem from the pandemic
response and particularly under the
biden administration where not only are
they not promoting therapeutics they're
actively trying to stymie the
distribution of things like monoclonal
antibodies
people are dying because of this that is
criminal
well and no governor for so long people
didn't even know that there were options
for treatment when we rolled out the
sites we started getting messages to my
office from other states people saying
hey i didn't even know this was out
there can you help me get it in my state
and that's a real real problem that
people didn't know that there was help
available
well and the federal government
obviously governor knew there was going
to be trouble right about now because
joe biden a couple of months ago said
you know we're entering the winter of
death and it's going to be a winter of
severe illness but then you know
yesterday the day before joe biden said
hey
we know it's bad but give us more time
uh so we can get the tests out so we can
get the pfizer pills out and things like
that
but you know that's why he was elected
he and ron klain made the pitch when
they were running when he was running as
for president ron claine was one of his
assistants he said you know hire me
because i've been in government my whole
life and i can get stuff done and now i
think that's the frustration not only
down in florida but all across the
country because the federal government
has handled it so badly there are a lot
of people who want tests
who want treatment and can't get it
his promise was he would shut down the
virus and he demagogue donald trump
every day he blamed trump for covet
cases and deaths he didn't blame china
which is really where the blame belongs
but he said it was all trump's fault and
then he would shut it down and not only
has he not shut it down you have cases
and hospitalizations in parts of the
country like we've never seen before so
that fundamental promise he made to the
american people he has absolutely failed
upon and honestly it was demagoguery
from the beginning you can't just
magically shut down a respiratory virus
he should have talked about what he
would do to help mitigate and to provide
these treatments and that wasn't what he
was doing so that central promise has
failed
he should not have been demagoguing
trump like he did and now when he sees
the results he's saying well it's not
really the federal government's
responsibility it's all about what the
state should be doing i can tell you
steve that's not what he was saying to
florida in texas this summer he was
blaming us for not imposing mandates and
restrictions
even though you know we've done much
better in terms of our uh uh society and
economy and education so that's just
what they're doing and i think they've
got themselves in a big rut because they
made all these grand promises they used
it to try to win the election uh and now
the the bills are coming due and they're
just not able to cash the checks
so uh representative eric swalwell out
in california he was just a few days ago
blaming republicans for prolonging covet
this was what he tweeted out as we in
2021 mired in a deadly pandemic you
should know who has prolonged it these
guys republican liars your vacation
canceled your kids back to virtual
learning and back to masks everywhere
for blame look no farther than hashtag
these guys yet he travels to florida and
he is caught without a mask as he's
sitting down in a chair not at a dinner
table talking to this lady here with his
baby next to him no mask aoc recently
was down down there right after the
christmas break or new year's and she
was seen without a mask and hugging
people and having
which you're allowed to take your mask
off at a dinner table so um that was
fine but hugging people at this party or
at this club
and uh dancing around no mask and then i
heard you i think you were on with sean
on fox and you said there were six
governors that you know of from some of
these democratic states that you know
have been down in the state of florida
vacationing so what do you make of this
rules for the and not rules for for thee
and not for me
well ainsley the number of lockdown
politicians that have locked down their
people lectured their people
cast aspersions on florida who then turn
around and then seek refuge in florida
is so much it's become a cottage
industry i mean you have governors you
have mayors you have members of congress
they say one thing
and then they live under different sets
of rules and i think the thing about
florida is we've said you have the
ability to make your own decisions you
know we are not going to use the heavy
hand of government to curtail your
freedoms or to ruin your livelihoods and
those policies were policies that all
those people uh railed against uh and
yet they'll come down here and bask in
the florida sunshine in the florida
freedom so i'm glad that florida is a
refuge for people i mean you know we are
we're happy with what we're doing uh but
it really shows you that this is a
ruling class mentality where they think
that they can impose these on other
people but that they should not have to
follow all the dictates that they
constantly spout and i know you're
running a state and you're also trying
to run a family and your wife uh casey's
going through cancer treatment i know
how tough things have been uh please let
just just know we're pulling for you and
we know uh how to especially with a
young family there is no timeouts so uh
best of luck with the treatment the the
outpouring for my wife has been
fantastic a lot of your viewers and just
know she and i
very much appreciate that it makes a
difference and the prayers make a big
difference so thanks everybody who's had
her back thank you uh governor thanks
for joining us today
thank you
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis